l'accordo ragazzi prima di cominciare
soltanto una roba allora ho fatto un
test per capire se funzionava un attimo
cleverbot ho provato a scrivere delle
cagate così giusto per vedere cosa
risponde io gli ho scritto ma ciao e lui
ma ciao ciao io ovviamente ho risposto
ma ciao ciao ciao perché mi sembrava
giusto
poi lui mi fa come mi chiami e ho
risposto e lui mi fa qualcosa cioè io io
nel vero senso della parola io
vabbè lasciamo perdere a tutti i ragazzi
e benvenuti nessuno video sono fa vj ci
siamo trovati su cleverbot dopo tipo si
presenta ragazzi sono passati anni da
sta cosa ma perché avevano tolto il
microfono e non potevo più parlare e mi
sta sul cazzo sta cosa comunque hanno
rimesso microfono quindi voglio vedere
che cosa è cambiato la l'ultima volta
che se mi ha lasciato cosa è successo a
bella zio ago sai bene grazie al
perfetto e sta bene
senti ma l'ultima meta ti stavo
rimorchiando ti ricordi per caso
rimorchiando ti ricordi perché no non si
ricorda merda ma ciò vuol dire che ti
devo rimorchiare da capo cioè una roba
ragazzi sono in tensione
no io sono femmina tomasky ok che cazzo
c'entra avere ragazzi andiamo subito al
sodo perché se no non ci muoviamo più lo
sa già continua questa 6 almeno la metà
gnocca di quella nella pubblicità 18 se
almeno la metà non ci credo che la presa
la presa tutta o mio figlio è la prima
volta riprende una frase così lunga al
microfono è un record esami ha risposto
sta pensando ci sta pensando ovvio
perché non lo sa subito cota sia quella
di sotto è rifatta almeno tu puoi essere
ben la naturale di meloni
finché la cosa significa che si sta
rifacendo il trucco prima di rispondere
mi sembra giusto no 12 ore e mezza di
attesa e poi no ma [ __ ] will you
speak to mi na sega no
la sega no non c'è verso oggi ce l'ha
coi ragazzi non so perché hai provato a
rifarsi il trucco ma ha capito di non
essere bella come quella di sotto quindi
devo chiederle una foto quindi mi mandi
una foto nuda ma calmo voglio vedere più
che altro è la risposta sta cosa
no è che cazzo agostino però ma sai dire
solo no se mi risponde no ti giuro che
ti ammazzo ma [ __ ]
allora ragazzi non è così non è
fottutamente positivi chen yi puzza la
mamma balossa ha cambiato la prima
lettera va bè ragazzi dai proviamo una
cosa seria perché sono è da tanto che
non ci sentiamo ti sono mancato giusto
per capire se no mi dispiace mi sono
appena connessa ma quindi possiamo
chattare in modo erotico vero dilemma
positivi influence tommy ma per che cosa
mi risponde in inglese convogli gli
sfondoni via fermi ok suoi due want en
erotic set ritmi di one ton erotiche ma
come ma cosa centra un cieco ma no non
intendevo questo cazzo
ok mi esce su google scrivo questo vuol
dire che devo fare è una cosa 3 questo
tizio a ménage la tua amena fatte meno
la mamma so what are you up to write
sia io ti voglio tromba ok la cappa così
tipi di minibaev a chi se ne fotte va
bene lo stesso zia fammi capire un po
che cosa più sei dio a sentì non ci
stiamo capendo wanna sexy andiamo sul
chiaro perché qua non ci stiamo muovendo
più saiu armi con out vuol dire io sono
mica sono mica è no ma in questo caso
non potrei farlo vabbè cazzo duro fare
una roba non s'è oui je t'aime si sta
diventando una roba erotici ma mi sta
bagnando
che cazzo mista asciuga tutto qui ge
templio che cosa cazzo ha scritto
traduttore ditemi voi se devo andare sul
produttore per tradurre ste stronzate
amo più la maglia a venezia ti sei
lasciato andare alla fine è ragazzi e
l'acqua che era il bagnato quando uno si
basa non metterò mai questo video su
youtube si sono maschio forza poi no non
sono bagna stavo scherzando sono bello
asciutto anzi sono un font sei maschio
ma quindi non sei innamorato di me vero
da quando cazzo se ne esce che ho
parlato mezz'ora con un maschio ma
dimmelo chiazzo che vi che ha sprecato
meno tempo almeno una lava cazzo no no
no no no non ascoltano adesso non lo
dico io non sei innamorato di me io sono
un ragazzo
sì sì sì sì sì no no no non hai capito
un cazzo che qualcuno mi dia una mano
aiuto c'è un ragazzo che mi per se
qualcuno mi dia una mano cazzo non è
possibile
mica la mia no non mi consenti c'è stato
un malinteso
ok dobbiamo dobbiamo aggiustare le cose
in modo pacifico
no non kathleen film su per il culo quel
ti piace anche secondo quindi non
possiamo avere un rapporto ha capito
ecco io sto sudando no che cosa fai il
triste quanti casi non mi ha detto
quando stiamo chattando vale è stata la
tua esperienza ott più bello
voglio vedere che cazzo mi sparano raga
è una cosa giusto per curiosità e quando
si sono detti ciap minchia da orgasmo
proprio
o cazzo oh cazzo no non sono il tuo
amore sono lorenzo e o vent'anni che
quindi non noti invece che lo si no
allora [ __ ] eva
no non lo può capire è poco ma sentire
cosa ma hai una sorella rimorchio
lasciamo un po di cambio di di soggiorno
o tremila donne un paio cazzo facciamo
scambio io ti do un deal don't tell
infili fai quello che vuoi tu mi dai tua
sorella e lunga est avrà mica prima
grande ci metterà facciamo che ti faccio
un occhio nero a bello ma guarda che è
che io di nero c'è un'altra cosa
cosa sta succedendo sei simpatico invece
sono simpatico sono famiglia e grazie sì
se tu mi piaci
vieni a casa e ti faccio schioppa mia
sorella
vediamo se si riesce a capire qualcosa
di quello che sto dicendo sì si sta
arrivando arriva arriva
il che razza è il tuo cane ma non è un
cane non so cosa sei abituato a trovate
senti ma gli scopi i cani
fammi capire che il caso ok ti piace io
non posso scrivere ste cose lega non
posso guardare mentre le scrivo perché
mi mi vergogno non ho visto rifiutando
ogni gira non voglio c è una roba
no no no no no no devi dire no ma ovvio
che no [ __ ] ma ti pare c'è ma
scherzi sì c'è anche volendo come come
fossi adesso è diventato non cambiato
risposto grande ovvio che si sta
diventando la roba sporca è chiaro
ragazzi vedono che il cazzo volete
scritto l'ultima volta che ho provato
cleverbot chiedigli cantasse una canzone
va bene da grant ami una canzone dhabi
che sono così di vedere che cosa mi
risponde che non è che canzone facciamo
she looks of the day
il paese casa ma voglio dire che cazzo
ti sto scherzando dai mi chiamo paolo
ok bravissimo amica che prestazione
bellissima ragazza mi è piaciuto ma la
canzone no fammi capire che cangia la tu
ma come io canto che ne so ma rifiuti
ora no install mons il lineup hanjin
darò bari più clausura
mari più cloud esatto chiazzo rendere 3
da e vabbè lasciamo ragazzi è stato in
quanto sa concludo perché non ne posso
più di sei bagnata almeno un po chi sei
cani almeno un po no non sei bagnata
avermi bagno io che tanto ci ha già
pensato brand è stato bello rigiocherà
cleverbot col microfono anche se avrei
fatto volentieri a meno
credimi ma molto meno concludi to
l'episodio vediamo che il cazzo mi tira
fuori stavolta mi basta una gran
conclusione tranquilla e senza problemi
concludiamo che noi due siamo insieme ma
se tanto robot in più rubati in meno
quindi ragazzi servizio è piaciuto
solito lasciato commento mi piace anche
la pagina di facebook e che nei video
descrizione essere usciti sia feci
vediamo prossimo vitobello ragazzi nel
appreso solo prossimo video bella
ragazza
me l'ha preso come in base alla risposta
chiudo calmo non di caccia non dio
stronzata asp e che vuole rispondere
l'altro favi po come l'altro favi in che
senso quale altro mio amico allora
ascolta cefa vili e cosa che il discorso
stiamo avendo ove la nutella e che è qua
e qua arriva arriva aspetto questa è
come prefetti serve vuoi la nutella
altro favi ragazzi si fa vi ma sei tu
c'hai caccia fa sto cercando prof.sa
vigente o no io sono andrea al tuo
fidanzato
dai ragazzi